this is a production of Cornell
University
okay without any further ado I'm here to
tell you a couple of things first of all
I'm proud to stand up here and say that
what Laurie and I are about to do today
continues to be a good indication of how
when conducted properly Cooperative
Extension in new york state in the
united states is still alive and well
and still a very important part of the
land grant mission that i hope continues
to maintain its important as we as we
head through difficult budget time so
that's my political statement for the
start of this thing my personal
statement is it's always wonderful to
have colleagues like Lori who are make
for a wonderful partnership where we
know there's a need we identify the way
we want to approach it we identify the
behaviors we want to change and we go
after it and do it in very classic
Cooperative Extension fashion so that's
the message for today you have to wonder
what you all do with yourselves coming
out to listen to a long talk on a day
like this but we're glad you're here
nevertheless why do you know lawns why
what is it doing here why do I care
about it I don't understand we should
completely get rid of these things and
the fact is long has both cover a lot of
grass a lot lot grass a lot a lot of
land this is from Alessi of 2007 he did
some spectral work from a NASA satellite
and you can see the land cover it's I
think it's about thirty three thirty I'm
not even sure exactly the land coverage
but you can see that it tends to be
focused around urban areas it has
enormous economic value it's an 85
billion dollar in industry industry
nationally and lawns makeup sixty-five
percent of that economic value so golf
and sports and sod all the other things
account for the other thirty five
percent nationally in New York State we
did a survey back in two thousand three
so that's fairly dated now but at that
time it was a five billion dollar
industry and in New York about 75% of
the economic value came from people
buying stuff for their lawns not hiring
a service but buying things
or their lawns equipment fertilizers
pesticides seed services because we
don't have a farm gate value the NASD
this the stats they did it for us in
2003 based on the way we projected the
amount of money people spend on lon so
we have a lot so why do we have long we
need lawns and and we need lawns because
we do this to where we have lawns when
you have a high percentage of impervious
surface you have enormous impact on the
way water for example will move through
that system so it then heightens the
importance of these vegetated green
spaces and I'm arguing a particular part
of it we can see from this slide is
lawns and so how do we view the lawn as
something that helps us or released
recognized as the people in the
Chesapeake Bay Area have recognized that
this is a significant land use that's
may not serve a purpose out here to have
it doing the things we do with it in
urban areas in Nebraska but in areas
where we have a lot of pavement it makes
a lot of sense to have something to
mitigate the problems that the payment
card very good so so we know lawns are
everywhere there's a lot of impervious
surface we also know that the climate is
changing dramatically right the climate
is changing anybody that works in
growing something recognizes that this
is some data from 2011 from the from
NOAA and at that time they were keeping
weather records for a hundred and
seventeen years and two parts of the
United States had the warmest year on
record the march to august two thousand
eleven growing season and in the
northeast and in this the south central
sub midwest here had one hundred and
eighteen hundred night so the in the top
10% of the warmest years ever so the
climate is changing lots of lawns how do
we get to love a good long why would we
embark on a project like this well let
me give you some background that's my
job is to sort of set the stage for Lori
to pick up on a little bit about our
program and what we focused on a
programmatic approach to how we do
things high-touch high-tech used to meet
a lot 20 years ago when I started an
extension doesn't mean as much now but i
want to show you we've come through the
ranks on thinking like that an extension
we've had some good scholarship and of
course measuring impact we've been at
this a long time in turf this is from
the United States Golf Association green
section record from July of 1921 when
Cornell was commended for starting a
short course for parking grounds
managers levittown the original the
original subdivision suburban love a
good lon place and so as this happened
in the 40s right at the same time not
well not long after about 20 years later
we started to realize the pressure on
the Long Island groundwaters the ground
water that that Long Island citizens use
for drinking water was under siege from
agriculture and at the same time we
looked at urban area so historically we
did put the Cornell in cooperation with
the water resources 2 2day Bolden did a
bunch of surveys of lawns on Long Island
in the 1970s looking for our lawns leaky
or things leeching out into the
groundwater and what they found was that
if you look at the data as the lawn ages
the organic matter gets accumulating in
there starts to supply a fair amount of
nitrogen right right in the weeds we're
getting with room in the 70s we figured
out we knew that this was happening now
to be honest we're slow learners but now
these people outside of the turf field
just published a paper this path this
past month on household manager
practices in effect on global warming of
homeless Orban lawns and what they
concluded was as the lawn ages you
shouldn't fertilize it as much because
it increases
global warming problem by putting out
nitrogen fertilizer that leaks into the
atmosphere nitrogen is 300 times more
potent as a greenhouse gas than carbon
so it's interesting to see how things
that started here at Cornell are now
still very currently a part of the
thinking about taking care of lawns so
we've had a strong research base for a
long time very much focused on
environmental quality that has been the
emphasis of our program for a very long
time we also have a focus with our
collaboration with the New York State
IPM program on a progressive pest
management approach that's both
ecologically based and uses I p.m. and
finally from an extension perspective
our work is always focused on enhanced
decision-making it's one thing to create
information that that you just let loose
at a website or on a booklet it's
another thing when you take that
information and help people to make
decisions to make make their lives or
the environment better so here's our
programmatic approach that was the
history and maybe our focus our approach
to this particular project fits in like
every other thing that we do what's the
issue what's the audience let's get a
resource going let's work at work that
resource in various venues and now of
course you can add the Augmented
environments we do webinars and Google
chats and skype and everything else that
we do we're connected to Geneva so this
is the high-touch and of course we're
still learning how to work in those
augmented environments for the high tech
part and then we check out how we did
you know we put all this energy into
doing all this work did we change
behavior this is I think a thing a lot
of extension people don't always get
that they're just putting the
information out there isn't it isn't the
role of extension there's a lot of dopes
that put information out all over the
place they don't help you make decisions
and that's a singular science-based
focus of Cooperative Extension at least
from my understanding so an issue closer
to lawns as environmental assets was
when I got here in 1996 we had just
signed the New York City watershed
agreement i sat on a governor's
channel with particularly protecting the
resources on the east of Hudson urban
water the urban watershed that's the
east of Hudson and primarily phosphorus
loading now we Marty Petrovic and I did
a bunch of work over the years looking
at leaching and run off of different
compounds so we had the research we put
together that research with colleagues
in New England to sort of get a better
handle on from a large perspective but
here from an extension perspective we
developed an almanac we looked at lawn
care and water quality in a calendar
format so it was January you opened it
you could look see what should I be
doing in January what are the kinds of
things if I want to have a good lawn and
protect water quality what are the kinds
of things you can do so we then did a
bunch of training for several years with
this Almanac that's got to be 18 years
old now and when we went back and
surveyed how effective we were from the
money we got from the New York City
watershed forty percent of those we
educated this went out and soil tested
for phosphorus we said to them ninety
percent of the lawns east of Hudson
don't need supplementary phosphorus if
you test and you got this number don't
put it out there and so we had enormous
impact in the training that we did and
overall the four or five hundred people
that we trained particularly through
this process master gardeners and
otherwise also we raise their awareness
they had no idea all the ways taking
care of their lawn could impact water
quality now this is translated further
in some of my professional extension
work the Gulf superintendents and the
golf industry came and gave us 160
thousand dollars to develop a best
management practice set of principles
that's online that was both reviewed by
our scientific colleagues for accuracy
and also by people in the division of
water and a division of pesticides for
the Dec so they looked at what we wrote
here so it's congruous with their
regulations and we're currently in a
phase two
we're now assessing superintendents use
and changing of behavior for now that
they have this resource okay on our way
to the e-book and which is to me the
height of the the star of the show here
obviously climate change is a big issue
and I mentioned it earlier it's one we
think about all the time because this is
when people take care of their lawns or
their gardens they can potentially have
an impact and their practices may change
we've done some research about this this
was actually a class I taught a bunch of
undergrads and grad students we got
together and ask this question this was
one of the this was the number one
downloaded turf article from the turf
information file from 19 from 2009 so we
asked a question how much carbon are we
burning how much are we sequestering got
some good preliminary data that many
many have published beyond this we also
published a paper looking at how the
changing environment increases the
conducive environment for a foliar
pathogen in this case dollar spot I
published it with RT caetano and we
actually confound looking at weather
records over a 50-year period how pest
pressure from the environment has
changed all these black dots are where
the environment is getting more
conducive to this particular foliar
pathogen so we got some foundational
data mean climate changes the issue we
see how it's impacting disease pressure
we published a research article on it
and we use that forecasting information
in our weekly newsletter that we've
written about our surveys from in the
Journal of extension an example of just
in time education and the forecasting
and predicting of these issues are part
and parcel to our weekly newsletter and
also well integrated into our forecast
website that's managed through the
Northeast climate Center so again a
commercial way where we've identified
how climate change is altering pest
pressure how do we help the managers
make better decision
by regular contact with them through the
shortcut newsletter and forecasting how
their the risk for the particular
problems might be so they might not use
as many pesticides and taking care of it
the bethpage State Park is another
example of some of the decision-making
work that we've done in this case we
started with the New York State Park
policy people who wanted a banned
pesticides across the entire state park
system and we said maybe you should
treat golf courses differently so I
partnered up with Jennifer grant for the
New York State IPM program and started
working with the 27 state golf courses
throughout New York State we've got a
resource here developed by Bob port mess
when he was a graduate student and
utilized in his time now as an extension
associate funded through the new york
state parks department and we've taught
national seminars we are current you
know we started working at bethpage now
we work at all 27 state parks we've had
pretty good superintendent extension
update I'm from our website hits and our
extension colleagues continue to use
this in their training Pat vitam uses it
in her class at the University of
Massachusetts and those that have done
gone through our national training said
that 25 to 40 percent by using tools
developed through this we're able to
reduce their environmental impact of
their pest management program so again
how do we help people make decisions and
how do we determine how they're doing on
the other end little gloating this is
the book I did a number of years ago
this is the top-selling what as was the
n raised now was cat now it's pals this
book is still their number one seller
and again it's a tool devised for
helping people decide what to do okay
just to remind you of the approach that
we take and the introduction to Laurie's
effort here are thinking based on all
that I've led to to this point is that
lawns are a resource in an increasingly
urbanized environment so when you ask
people what a sustainable lon is they'll
give you a variety of answers right
depending on what perspective they come
to you know what makes a lawn and
environmental acid or what makes a long
weekend
Staind so we sort of wordsmith different
definitions but optimizes the functional
aspects of the lawn in harmony with
conserving natural environment under
economically font sound and socially
responsible you know all of us adapt
these things for whatever crop were
working on but our emphasis has been on
the functional aspects of the law not
necessarily how it looked how it looks
and that's why this isn't love a great
lawn it's love a good lon now why do
this well the Gallup poll people are
when you ask the degree to which
Americans worry about environmental
problems this is from two thousand eight
or nine I think and you can see that how
many worry about these particular
environmental problems water pollution
drinking water pollution global warming
has about fifty percent not much at all
think about global warming now this is
four years ago so it may have changed a
little bit but the point I'm building to
is environmental actions in the u.s.
they've there's been little increase in
general and environmental action most
people the biggest thing they do is
recycle across-the-board the biggest
thing they do is recycle now the
challenge we face in getting people to
look at lawns as an environmental asset
is very much tied to the economy again a
gallup poll taken all the way into 2011
which one of these statements about the
environment and economy do you most
agree with protection of the environment
should be given priority even at the
risk of curving at curbing economic
growth or economic growth should be
given priority even if environment
suffers to some extent and you can see
the gap from the 85 95 when they first
started asking these questions in right
around the turn of the century you
started to see well I sort of think the
environment is important but you know I
got to have money right and so it was
you could see the downturn in the
economy right here we're now a much
bigger concern for economic stability
that environmental quality and you can
see how these things are hovering right
around each other so to get people to
pay attention to environmental issues it
has to make economic sense it's actually
an easy sell once you tell people caring
about the environment inherently could
mean you're going to spend less it tends
to balance those things for people now
this was a tough go even internally the
American Society of landscape architects
in cooperation with Lady Bird Johnson in
the u.s. Botanic Garden said we want
this sustainable initial sustainable
sites initiative which is essentially
lead you know the building standards for
lawns I'm sorry for the outside for the
landscape lead for the landscape and in
right out of the gate they basically
said well you can't have a sustainable
site if you have any grass because there
were no recommendations for having grass
in this initiative so we put a class
together and did some work but what I
can tell you is we're up against quite a
battle both you know this issue our own
peers don't seem to understand the role
that these things play and we all know
how this governs a lot of the landscapes
that we manage but in the end of
difficult economic times people tend to
reduce their commitment to environmental
quality and I think this is what makes
the cell we're doing with this new
project even tougher so you have to make
Environmental Quality make economic
sense and that's exactly the approach we
took with this book so is this mean for
lawn care well my career has led me to
this point where I believe we've got to
anticipate the effect that climate
change is going to have on managing the
things that we're doing we've got a
position the lawn as a resource it can't
just be a beauty contest it can't be I
got to have a good long because the
Jones is down the block have a good lawn
and I want to have the best lawn and we
know from current economic and sort of
environmental awareness surveys a lot of
people still feel like they got to have
a good long to keep up with their
neighbors that's not gone away and we
must adopt a progressive approach that
balances costs look and function and
that is where we get
this wonderful resource now that
capitalizes on a lot of the things that
I've talked about in the past but now
really utilizes that that technology in
a really meaningful way and you know not
like it's any great deal people make I
books but for us this is leading edge in
some of the Cooperative Extension stuff
that we see so without any further ado
I'm going to transfer just two minutes
past sorry to my colleague glory and a
few more minutes on a few more slides
and then i'm going to show you sections
of that of the ibook so as Frank alluded
to several reasons why it was a top
priority to to think about lawn care for
him and for me equally um I was thinking
about why should I care about lawn care
and with our garden based learning
program certainly thinking about how
people are environmental stewards is a
top priority so so that was an easy sell
for me the several other reasons are
that there are two point eight million
acres of home lawns in New York State
alone so what people do with their lawns
really makes it matters so that was
another compelling reason and also in
Cornell Cooperative Extension around the
state we have county offices in our
county offices report they get phone
calls from the the public and they
report that fifty percent of their calls
related to gardening and lawn care fifty
percent of them are lawn care and so in
some counties that's eight hundred calls
a year people calling up and asking
about what to some some practice that
relates to lawn care so another
compelling reason for me to be involved
and to for me to get the people I work
with the horticulture educators and the
Master Gardener volunteers involved and
then certainly Frank relayed a lots of
research and new on information that's
coming out about lawns and how lawns are
environmental asset as well as some new
regulations he didn't touch on some of
the new regulations but there's some new
regulations out there as well so another
reason why we want those cooperative
extension educators and Master Gardener
volunteers
be aware of the best management
practices that are based on
research-based information and then also
Frank was willing to do partner with me
so certainly I could pick other topics
but if I don't have a research faculty
member who can help me develop that
resource with their expertise it's hard
to go forward so that's that's critical
the another critical thing that led us
in the direction of trying out and I
book was that we did get funding from
New York State I pm-2 to help offset the
cost of developing this book so critical
reasons and so why did we decide that we
would try to create an ibook and we
wanted to main be maintained our current
be current and connected to where people
are getting information and this report
is actually from 2012 so I think it's
probably even more the numbers are
higher now but a Pew Research Center
revealed that forty-three percent
forty-three percent of americans aged 16
or older have read an e-book as a source
of pleasure or gathering information so
so people are using ebooks and so maybe
extension could be there those of you
her laughing I know why and so so again
the Frank I already showed you this and
the handout will connect you to to
iTunes so I did the e-book in itunes and
there are many logistical reasons why
did that the main being my my knowledge
of programming is limited in itunes
iBook author makes it somewhat
accessible for somebody with my
knowledge to do it there I will not tell
you it was easy but I couldn't do it in
a different format but they made it
slightly easy so in order to get to the
ibook which can only be viewed on a Mac
smartphone or I or a mac laptop that
has I book on it so it has some limits
that way or an iPad but if you go into
itunes and you search under lawn care
you get like this many books and none of
them are based on fact with
research-based information and i'll tell
you how exciting some of them are how
much time do you want to spend on lawns
this book on organic lawn care it's only
250 pages long and then this one a
hundred lawn care tips number 5 says
think about your lawn just before going
to bed I'm pretty sure most of the
people were trying to reach who are
taking care of their lawns are not going
to spend the time to shift through some
of these so really our intention with
our our I book ebook is to make it much
more accessible to those who want to
spend a limited amount of time carrying
thinking about their lawn so really the
average lon person to really maximize
the number of people who actually look
at the information and do the right
thing change their behaviors so yeah
you'll see that those books are
essentially our PDF their PDF we can put
PDFs up we actually an extension know
how to do that and so Craig can edit um
so but this I'd look um I'll show you
some clips from it and the intention was
to keep the text limited and you can see
it's actually only 45 pages long and and
if no one read beyond beyond page 12
most people will be doing the right and
did what was in the first 12 pages they
be doing the right thing so beyond those
first 12 pages are just like bonuses for
the people are geeking out about their
lawns and and we do have a section where
we ask people to actually go to a
Qualtrics survey and they can give us
feedback on what they they get behaviors
they might have changed by reading the
book so we have that sort of built into
the book a little opportunity for
feedback so so this is sort of the
layout of the book and now I'm going to
escape this and go try to quickly go to
hide books here
so if you download it you then open up I
book and it will actually come out it'll
look a little different when you first
open it this was just the last page I'm
actually going to compute it slightly
different so you see what happens when
you open it so when you open it up you
get the really the last page that you
looked at and then let me see if I can
might have to keep it down for a second
I would just wanted to show you the
table of contents and now i'm going to
go to the thumbnails and then i'm going
to go big screen so these this thumbnail
is just certain just shows you a quickly
what's in the book ruff ruff thing in
the book and in it this is the first
section here four steps to success these
are the first actually only 10 pages
because there's two intro pages and and
so I'm going to actually show you first
the intro movie the simple steps that we
are trying to get across to to introduce
people to really the most important
things they knew need to do to care for
their lawn and so we have a number of
these videos all of them are less than
most of them are about a minute long
some are the hottest one is three
minutes but most of them are quick and
the whole the whole book really aims at
being an easy short read and friendly
words not trying not to use any language
that that you know a typical maybe even
eighth grader wouldn't already have that
vocabulary so back to the four steps
this is these are the four steps in
which if they just did these few things
it would be terribly exciting and we
would have a great impact on on how
lawns are an environmental asset and
their lawn care people are environmental
stewards so I'm going to skip right to
make adjustments so you can jump around
easily in the in the book and down here
you can even flip back to whatever page
you previously on and again make
adjustments we list keep the mower blade
sharp mow grass hire mulch grass
clippings mo tree leaves in the fall
patch week or bare spots and I'm going
to skip to the mo grass higher and I'm
going to see if I can i can actually
going to flip back i'm going to go to
sharpen your mower blade so with all the
videos as with the words in the book
most all that is we're saying do this as
opposed to well you could do this or you
could do the
or this we essentially went to but these
are not necessarily avid gardeners who
want to know all this information and
delve into it and wants to make
decisions these are people were like I
have this house I have this lon what the
heck am I supposed to do and we're
saying just do this do this do this and
and just trying to address that audience
you don't want all whole bunch of
options there's no no no what can i do
to do the right thing and so all of the
videos really focus on on just do it
this way right and and so as Frank
mentioned all of these videos were were
filmed and edited by professionals so we
didn't we didn't make these we might
have a structured how they would come
out but we didn't make him so again I'm
serve going to flip through the first 10
pages do less skip spring feeding that
oh and I should also say all of our
images to all of our images we had to
because it was it was out there and I
iTunes all of our images had to have
been our images but I also must tell you
I found great images on flickr and if
you go to those that allow you to use
them with recognition got great images
on lawns and Flickr I know everybody's
looking for those and then so this is
really page 11 and I would this is also
a very short short video but this is
that was the sort of bulk of the content
that we that we want people to focus on
and you can always go back up to either
the thumbnails or the table of contents
and flip through the book some more i'll
just show you advanced care just to
highlight what we have in advance care
and feeding which is what lots of people
think of fertilizing as feeding we
consider that in the advanced care
section it's not really part of that for
those first 11 pages that really mostly
you want people to use a sharp mower
blade and if they everyone did that the
fuel consumption
would be saved would be great and i will
show you again even information about
insect pests and weeds is in the
advanced care i'm going to see if it'll
go to the insect section for us maybe oh
just a little sluggish so in the insect
section we actually throughout the book
i have a number of galleries photo
galleries which you can embed in the
book and so you can add content that way
as well as this interactive image and it
will can flick on it and get some
additional information and again you can
very easy to flip through the book this
way people can quickly find something
that oh I wanted to know about that and
it end as I said all the way back I have
a place where you can share feedback and
that's where I want to mention that we
haven't really launched this book
because we finished it up in the lawn
care season is a little under the under
the weather right now so people aren't
really thinking about loans but we plan
to launch it this spring and we've done
a sort of a soft launch but we will
fully launched it and hopefully get some
good press and some sending it out to
those people we want to take a look at
it and get some feedback but even though
we haven't really sent it out to a wide
selection of people i have actually had
people click on the yes that this book
was helpful and an exciting thing was
that the things that they say they were
going to change so that goes to two
questions and asked if you're going to
change any behavior and three responses
i got was i'm going to change how I
fertilize I'm going to remove the high
spots in my lawn so I don't scalp my
lawn and then I'm going to stay on
keeping my mower blade sharp so already
the indications from those few people
are like ok they're getting it there
the message because maybe we're keeping
it simple enough we're not giving them
too much information very few people
would sit through Frank's 20 brief
minutes about lawn care and you guys are
very polite and and so so we really
tried to sort of entertain them as well
as try to deliver that information and
as far as as next steps go I'm this is
kind of the the Bible for lawn care in
our Cooperative Extension system I just
wanted to go back to the not
acknowledgments and and so I but I have
the opportunity to take this and make
easy up sites you might see that it's
already version 1.1 has already found
things that I needed to update so it's
easy enough for Frank to feed me
information and then i can make updates
in the text and those people already
downloaded the book can then can will
get noticed that that it's been updated
so so that's that's pretty pretty easy
to do and what we can also do is we have
about seven videos in there if we get
get additional resources we can change
some of the the text to add more videos
that we didn't just didn't have the
resources to produce any more than seven
so one of those might be related to the
under what circumstances should you be
mulching Leafs or what conditions
because there are some in disabilities
who who thought that leaf mulching
requiring everyone to mulch their lease
would be wonderful way to save money but
there are circumstances under which they
won't mulch well and people won't like
it so that's one thing that we're
looking forward to in the future as well
as using this as the court of the core
portion of the Master Gardener volunteer
training about long cares so with that
we have about five more minutes maybe
take some questions or comments
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu